all of this leads up to we are now
nearing the end of the campaign the the
election is next week
and joe biden is called in he hobbles
into virginia his closing pitch is not
that terry mcauliffe is going to be a
good governor of virginia his closing
pitch is trump trump the trump trump
mctrumpy trump trump trump trump trump
now you may have noticed that donald
trump isn't running for governor of
virginia you may have noticed that
donald trump does not hold any public
office
you may have noticed that donald trump
did not campaign with glenn youngkin
so he has nothing to do with this race
but the democrats have to rely on trump
in order to get out their base because
when trump's not on the ballot their
base doesn't care so joe biden instead
just says trump over and over and over
and over
there's not a trump rally donald trump
donald trump donald trump donald trump
now he doesn't want to talk about trump
anymore
well
i do donald trump trump trump trump
donald trump donald trump trump former
president trump's donald trump's donald
trump donald trump trump i love this one
trump donald trump donald trump donald
trump trump trump
okay so what do you think their theme is
are you getting any hints here hey just
say trump over and over because this old
daughtering fool of a president who's
botched the easiest presidency in the
world this is the easiest presidency
ever he inherited a vaccine he inherited
an economic boom because we were going
to come out of the pandemic all he had
to do was sit there and continue to be
barely sentient that's all he had to do
and he somehow blew that
all he has and all the democrats have is
shouting trump's name
that's it
and of course lying about
about glenn juncken
because the idea is that you can say
anything you want it by the way this is
how they got trump the way they got
trump is by saying that people like mitt
romney milk toast human beings mitt
romney is the least offensive human
being who has ever walked the earth
truly
he's he's as bland as a piece of bread
with with not even butter with margarine
okay that that's who mitt romney is and
they call and joe biden got up during
the 2012 campaign and said that mitt
romney was going to re-enslave black
americans
okay the democrats during that campaign
said the mitt romney strapped dogs to
the top of his car forcibly cut the hair
of gay kids
was some sort of cruel bigot and bully
and had binders full of women not
because he wanted to hire women but
because he hated women they said all
that about mitt romney
who is basically dull as ditch water
and so they're going to try and do that
again with now glenn youngkin
who again does not match the profile
when you do that republicans immediately
say okay fine whoever punches you guys
in the mouth we're good with
you want more trump that's how you get
more trump but
maybe that's what they want right maybe
the idea is that if we call everybody
trump maybe they'll actually nominate
people like trump in any case this was
joe biden's pitch so he claims that
glenn youngkin wants you to ban books
this is just an outright lie it is not
true
okay and that's not me saying that that
is the washington post saying that here
is joe biden just lying because he is a
doddering old liar
just a look how he's closing his
campaign
he's gone from banning a woman's right
to choose to banning books written by a
pulitzer prize and nobel prize winning
author tony morrison
okay he doesn't want to ban books
there's no evidence that glenn youngkin
has called for banning books the
washington post said as much now this is
a repeat of a lie that terry mcauliffe
told during debate
and there was a recent decision by
fairfax county public schools to remove
two books one called lawn boy by
jonathan evans and one called gender
queer by maya kobabi from high school
libraries because there were complaints
at a school board meeting because these
are basically pornography
okay but the bill that they are talking
about here does not do that the bill
does not allow parents to veto books or
take them off the shelves in fact all
that the bill which is what is issued at
issue here does
is
veto the ability of parents to be
informed that sexually explicit
materials were in the school library
that the school board gets to decide
whether the books stay in the schools
parents can pressure the school board
but the governor doesn't get to decide
which books get removed
all that has to happen under the bill
that young kin supports but that terry
mcauliffe does not is that parents would
be informed that there are sexually
explicit books
okay but it doesn't even do that as the
truth okay the truth is that it was only
instructional material
is what parents would be informed about
right the bill that was actually at
issue was a bill that said that if
there's instructional material
containing sexually explicit material
parents can opt out mcauliffe vetoed
that when he was governor of virginia
okay what does that have to do with
banning tony morris and nothing they're
just lying they're just making it up
even the washington post reporters and
philip wegman yesterday was like yeah
this is not true
but joe biden has to lie because the
idea is of course that every republican
is an emissary of the handmaid's tale
every republican is somebody who wants
women to become of glenn
that every republican is some sort of
brutal vicious
anti-gay
ridiculous person
everybody is trump everybody is trump
you know by the way this is why there is
a certain level of knee-jerk defensive
trump on the right because we understand
we do
that when trump said they're not
attacking
me they're not attacking me because they
hate me they're attacking me because
they hate you
he is right until donald trump ran for
president the media loved donald trump
then he ran for president and because
they hated trump supporters trump became
enemy number one
and this is perfect evidence of that
once again they're attacking glenn
juncken like he's donald trump not
because they hate trump but because they
hate junken that's the point and they
hate you somebody who's not willing to
vote for terry mcauliffe who's got two
thumbs and wants you to like and
subscribe